bonjour fabien alors vous êtes largement
intéressé à ce projet chinois où en
est-on qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire bonjour olivier alors oui les
images ont été diffusées en direct vers
5h30 du matin heure française donc à peu
près 11h30 heure locale dans la province
chinoise du henan et l'agent spatiale
chinoise la cns a à lancer le premier
module de sa station habitée qui devrait
pouvoir accueillir trois taïkonautes et
c'est autour de ce module que se feront
toutes les missions d'assemblage de la
station entre autres il y a deux
laboratoires spatiaux qui devrait y être
amarré dans les mois qui suivent
pour info le premier équipage chinois
doit arriver sur place au mois de juin
et cette station c'est un projet que la
cns a en tête depuis le début des années
90 et sur lequel elle s'est énormément
préparé alors que dans le même temps
pour des raisons qu'on évoque dans
l'article la chine n'a jamais participé
au programme de la station spatiale
internationale iss
qu'est ce qui va se passer très
concrètement à bord de cette station
fabien lors de ce que l'on sait
aujourd'hui il ya des choses qui
rappellent ce qui se passe déjà à bord
de l' iss il ya toute une palette
d'expérimentation mais aussi des
missions d'observation astronomique qui
sont prévues simplement il faut savoir
que l'avenir de liesse est confrontée à
plusieurs chamboulements surtout en
termes de financement donc de son côté
la station chinoise va permettre à pékin
d'entretenir de nouvelles collaborations
dans le domaine spatial
et il faut savoir que la chine a reconnu
a recueilli par dont déjà une
quarantaine de candidatures de pays qui
aimeraient utiliser sa station alors
comment ce projet chinois et ils
accueillis dans le monde quel est son
impact d'un point de vue géopolitique
alors c'est la plus grosse partie de
notre article
donc pour résumer on peut parler d'un
prolongement cosmique des tensions
internationales qui existe déjà en ce
moment sur la scène internationale donc
en premier lieu c'est l'administration
américaine qui s'inquiète le plus du
projet plus globalement des avancées
spatial de la chine
en gros la principale préoccupation de
washington
c'est de conserver sa suprématie dans la
conquête de l'espace
alors que l'ascension de la chine et les
coopérations qu'elle entreprend
notamment avec là aussi annonce plutôt
le développement d'un contexte multi
polaire dans le domaine il en découle
une situation géopolitique avec des
hostilités ouvertes dont on va sûrement
entendre de plus en plus parler les
prochaines années si beaucoup
fabien pour toutes ces précisions je le
rappelle famille arrive on vous lit sur
notre site
rt france point tv pour aller plus loin
sur le sujet de la station spatiale
chinoise